today I'm pleased to announce the
PlayStation VR were launched globally in
October 2016 for 399 dollars u.s. 399
euros 304 you guys just announced price
and release window which is the biggest
news out of today I was curious
primarily how are you were able to come
in at such a low price point relative to
your competitors who are obviously in
the eighth you know seven eight hundred
dollar range yeah it's funny because I
think a lot of the conspiracy theorists
think that we just look at everyone else
the price and then we choose hours
arbitrary but it's actually we've always
thought about this is a very sort of
value proposition driven you know device
and making it a great price that sort of
ties in with a ps4 to sort of extend
that is super important for another
price point from what you displayed is
the headset and components that allow
you to operate the headset correct but
you also showed PlayStation Move
controllers in there and in theory there
could potentially be like a camera of
some type involved as well are you guys
planning on doing a bundle that gives
users all of that stuff in one package
and if so what kind of price point would
that come in at yeah we're always
looking at opportunities of like hey
what are the gamers excited about what
are they looking for so we have another
noun straight now on that front but
obviously the move controllers with a
lot of the experience just they just
enhance it in such a way that we're
obviously looking into very heavily so
you're saying that players won't
necessarily have to invest in move
controllers to experience my station BR
know there's a lot of games out there
that sort of variety but dualshock 4
will drive the vast majority game some
games need no controller the guys that
headmaster been through all you have to
do is be able to headbutt something so
if you're an ex heavy metal fan or just
a ex soccer player then you'll have a
great time playing a game like that as
the director of you know third-party
relations how do you pick partners how
do you pick the games that you sort of
highlight at events like this yo I mean
we have an amazing staff all around the
world we've got developer relations
teams in Japan throughout Asia in face
and ski in London and then our team as
well but the important thing is also
just telling that story how easy is it
to work on the platform making sure that
the middleware providers like unity and
unreal are up to snuff on on the latest
SDKs and stuff like that
and then working with them to be like
what do you need super hyper cube right
by the guy's a polytron right that's a
really neat game where you're sort of
pivoting this geographic thing and
you're sort of looking around again
through it's like those japanese game
shows we got to pose to the right the
weibull yeah and that's just also a
small team so we're very hard to find a
nice breath of content that really
represents what's possible with PSP are
and then obviously just find out what
the devs what's important right how
important is certain aspects whether its
funding or promotion or you know PR
partnership stuff like that so I'd like
to say that we'd like to just try to
give better hugs that's the real
fundamental goal please tells me you're
giving better giving better hugs is
there going to be a hug simulator of any
time ah there's one right here if you
were honestly laters I'm gonna WI first
I've got the interview
you